nothing they can't do men and sets and
I'm sure it's gonna have the exact same
effect when Captain Marvel comes out and
then the black what all movie comes out
Marvel just has the winning recipe let's
go hey everybody it's Charlie like Chris
Evans says they got so much big stuff
coming down the pipeline Black Panther
blew it up we need to talk about the
sequel and if you didn't hear it he also
kind of back door confirms that they're
making a black widow movie so if you are
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos and I'm
doing a new round of that Infinity
Gauntlet giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video and obviously I
should say spoiler warning for Black
Panther if you have not seen the movie
yet so starting with number 10 easiest
one Ryan Coogler comes back they make it
one of the biggest tentpoles
of Marvel phase 4 that does not have
Avengers in the title pretty much
everybody that's not dead at the end of
the first film comes back and a few of
the dead characters - like T'Challa 's
father's gonna be there on the ancestral
plane he'll continue to go back to him
for advice and I will talk about king of
the Dead Black Panther stuff because
that's also one of the big things on my
list here but you can also bring back
kill monger on the ancestral plane as
well because he was one of the Black
Panthers and usually it's implied that
Black Panthers get to live on the
ancestral plane I'll be at some of the
rules about what goes on on that
ancestral plane were clearly defined so
I'll address that during this - because
spirituality mysticism is a big part of
Black Panther stories number 9 the
earliest we see that Black Panther
sequel is 2020
right now they have two films that
they've confirmed for Marvel phase four
they have spider-man 2 which is
happening right after Avengers 4 in 2019
then guardians 3 is dated for spring
2020 now Chris Evans is sort of backdoor
confirmed the Black Widow movie that
could also be released sometime during
2020 so Black Panther if they do three
films during 2020 could be that third
film the very earliest that they could
release it would be February 2020 so
depending on how fast they want to lock
all the actors and all the talent behind
the scenes down you'll hear about that
really soon
number eight here's a really big one
though developing Shuri as the next
Black Panther storyline that they
tee's during the first film it didn't
get a whole lot of play on social media
this week not as much as the other big
moments but there were a couple times
during the movie that they reference
Sheree eventually taking the mantle of
Black Panther from T'Challa the first
time was during that warrior Falls
coronation ceremony when in Baku ended
up challenging him they said does anyone
challenge him for the right to become
king of Wakanda and sure he raised her
hand it everybody just paused for a beat
like holy [ __ ] is she actually gonna
challenge him then there was a moment
that didn't make it past pre-production
they had done concept art of Sheree
wearing a version of the black panther
costume with her Panther gauntlets I
think what they originally intended when
they mocked this up is that she would be
wearing a version of it during this big
final battle when she had her gauntlets
on but they just introduced the idea of
T'Challa being king Black Panthers so I
don't think that anybody is gonna be
taking the mantle from him in the next
10 years but what I want them to do in
the sequel though is just tease her
designing her own black panther costume
the way that Iron Man teases new suit
functions new designs on the walls so
you might not actually see a new suit of
armor but you know that he's working on
one the same way they used all these
spider-man designs during homecoming to
tease the Avengers suit like we actually
just learned what this crazy-looking
backpack does I don't want to spoil
infinity warp but I've done a couple
iron spider videos I'll link one at the
end of this if you guys want to watch it
number 7 speaking of spider-man in the
wake of phase 1 Avengers becoming less
of a big thing going forward through
phase 4 he's one of the few guaranteed
money earners the Kevin Feige has in his
rolodex of solo movies like which heroes
make a lot of money which heroes sell a
lot of merchandise
spider-man is right there at the top of
that list like Home Coming made a lot of
money it's possible that Black Panther
makes more money than spider-man
homecoming but where spider-man really
makes his bank is in merchandise like
think spider-man movie is in the
billions of dollars Spiderman
merchandise tens of billions of dollars
so just don't be surprised if you see
spider-man embedded in the culture of
all these other solo movies the way that
they're going to be doing with Black
Panther now that he's so popular as for
literal spider-man Black Panther
crossover I think the closest we get
to that in any kind of black panther
sequel is just Sheree in spider-man I
think the only time you'll actually see
spider-man on screen with T'Challa is
during Avengers team-ups like during
infinity war in Avengers 4 number 6
though the actress that play Sheree
confirmed that she spent a lot of time
hanging out with Tom Holland on the set
of both of the Avengers films while they
were filming them they talked about her
helping him with his suit so while I
always think this Spider Man will stay
in the red and blue costume he'll always
be visibly identifiable as spider-man
what she can do is incorporate what
Condon design technology vibranium
things into his suit functionality like
she miniaturizes his web-shooters she
uses vibranium to make his webbing that
much stronger speaking about the black
costume of it all cuz I know there's a
lot of symbiote questions we have venom
obviously I think that at some point
they'll tease the idea of a black
spider-man costume but because I think
they want to keep him in that red blue
costume that if it does go black it'll
be like a camo mode that she
incorporates into it because the nanites
and vibranium can do just about anything
you could imagine
Iron Man is even incorporating nanites
into the idea of his bleeding edge
infinity war armor really big one though
number 5 namor the sub-mariner and
atlantis are teased in an active way
like here's this Easter Egg during
Ironman to offshore here you see this
little atlantis named war easter egg
that they don't directly call out that's
more of a passive easter egg
when I say actively teasing name or
somebody in the movie references
Atlantis in the idea that someone lives
there they don't have to literally bring
Namor on screen just introduce the idea
that he exists in the MCU and is a
potential threat to be introduced in a
future Avengers team-up film but another
easy one number four Black Panther king
of the Dead something that they only
teased during the first film we didn't
learn anything about the rules of the
ancestral plane what can they do other
than just communicate with him he
usually goes to them for advice during
times of great conflict or great crisis
of faith when he has internal problems
he's struggling with father help me give
me advice how do I be a good King
pushing it a little more dr. strange
territory number three the actual gods
of Wakanda the card the Orisha but
because we know that gods literally
exist in the Marvel's
universe the opening credits of the
movie tease the concept of the Panther
goddess now they need to show her at
some point even if they don't do those
other gods number two another big one
Black Panther Captain Marvel and the New
Avengers so by the time we get to the
Black Panther sequel twenty twenty or
twenty twenty-one at the latest
they will have been several big Avengers
roster changers Black Panther and
Captain Marvel will be the two most
powerful characters on the team
literally powerful in the case of
Captain Marvel and politically powerful
in the case of Black Panther they start
working together collaborating on the
ideas that will eventually lead to the
Ultimates in sending a potential
crossover points for the Marvel cosmic
movies the James Gunn and Kevin Feige
have been teasing so if you didn't know
James Gunn while he's also working on
guardians three has also been an advisor
for Marvel as they plan out the next ten
years of guardians adjacent space-based
Marvel movies they're calling that the
Marvel cosmic universe meaning that
you're gonna see a lot of space-based
movies that don't have guardians in the
title in right now they only have
guardians Thor and Captain Marvel as
space-based characters meaning that
we're gonna either introduce a bunch of
new characters or they're gonna start
mining those x-men characters when they
lock that deal down so once they get
them you could do Fantastic Four
Galactus Silver Surfer starjammers Shiar
Empire Nova is also a possibility but
the Nova Corps is gonna get destroyed
during infinity war so we'll see how
they deal with that but probably the
biggest thing and I know this is gonna
be a big question for the next couple of
years no actual x-men characters like
storm until we get that third Black
Panther film and I do think that there
will be multiple Black Panther sequels
but they haven't said anything beyond
2020 Kevin Feige says they do have about
20 movies planned but a lot of that
after 2020 could change depending on
what goes down with this Disney Fox deal
so it's kind of a waste of time to try
and predict stuff after 2020 so I'll say
yes they absolutely have to cross storm
over with black panther at some point
but the earliest they could possibly
work those characters into the movies
would be after 2020 and usually the lead
time that they need for movies is about
two years so starting in 2020 like when
the ink is dry
this Fox Disney deal then they can start
writing scripts that include the x-men
characters but you won't see those
movies till like two years after that so
I don't think we're gonna see a lot of
x-men popping up in Marvel films in a
big way till much much later but there
is a small chance that they just tease
the idea of mutants existing in the
Marvel Universe without literally
bringing them on screen well let me know
in the comments what do you want them to
do with the black panther sequel and
what will happen is is there will be
some new avengers posting really soon
now we can talk a little bit about the
soul gem because black panther is over
so I'll post that video as soon as I can
but congratulations to the latest
giveaway winner Merc with a mouth please
private message me so I can get your
contact details there was a new round on
this video I'll just name a new winner
when I post new Marvel so click here to
learn all about Captain Marvel in the
Black Panther movie and click here for
all my Black Panther Easter eggs thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]